let's jump to the story from the post
millennial Texas installs more razor
wire on Eagle Pass border after Supreme
Court said Biden could remove it Texas
will not back down from our efforts to
secure the Border in Biden's absence you
I was thinking about Civil War earlier
today and uh Fort Sumpter the start of
the Civil War we say Fort Sumpter and
then there's the uh First Battle of Bull
Run or the Battle of Manasses and I'm
thinking I wonder if in a 100 years
they're going to say the first battle at
Eagle Pass or they're going to say Eagle
Pass was the start of the second Civil
War I don't know you know it could just
we can't see the future it'll be
hindsight being 2020 100 years from now
they're going to look back and who knows
they could say the 2020 election they
could say January 6 they could say a lot
of things but right now what we're
looking at is an escalation of what is
effectively a Fort Sumpter esque moment
I said it was literally Fort Sumpter and
Ian got mad and he said no it's
figuratively cuz they're not actually
there and I'm like no I am saying it is
literally the circumstance an es of Fort
Suter in this instance the federal
government has asserted its jurisdiction
on a border however it is facilitating
criminal actions Customs and Border
Protection agents are committing
crimes serious humanitarian violations
and criminal activities Texas is trying
to stop them deploying armed
soldiers I think people need to
understand it's fascinating when I talk
about Civil War several years ago and
people are like you really think there's
going to be like armed soldiers marching
against the federal government it turns
out Texas deployed armed National Guard
to push out the feds who have went to
the Supreme Court asserted their
jurisdiction here and Texas said f off
and what does the what does the federal
government do well as long as long as
Texas is going to hold the line which I
think is awesome and I support them
doing that I think that we need to
encourage more red states to to follow
suit like West Virginia for instance
Ohio Kentucky send in the National Guard
as well to to give them some back right
now you think we should send him
National Guard to Texas uh well Texas's
national guard is there I believe that
they're going to hold the line on this
issue of our country being invaded right
now I would love to see West Virginia
not send ours in there to send back up
such a huge escalation yeah well I think
that that's warranted at this point you
have no idea what I would do if I was
the governor of West Virginia same
that's what I'm if I was in charge I
would I would I'm not talking 10 people
to get a headline I would send the
national guard down there and I would
encourage
my Governor I I would I would instruct
the West Virginia National Guard to
seize the CBP facility over at 340 we
know for a fact CBP agents they're on
camera smuggling humans yep children
children sex trafficking basic it it is
it is insane to me there was a video I I
showed earlier where someone actually
interviewed one of these agents as
they're facilitating human smuggling
working with
cartels and they go well it's crazy
they're letting them in and the guy I I
I don't know who actually produced the
video he says it basically it's strange
because when they say they're being
allowed in it's CBP who's doing it now
there's a facility over in West Virginia
not too far away from here a massive CBP
facil know this I didn't know that right
over there yeah and I'm
wondering how could anyone work I don't
care if you're if you're slinging coffee
yeah we know for a fact that CBP agents
are engaged in human trafficking right
now working children working with
cartels breaking the law and are staging
they are the they are the villains the
bad guys fighting against the
sovereignty and the law and there are
people in West Virginia like it's my job
yeah it's my job oh well you're a
scumbag but I think this question of how
will we remember this period of history
is really interesting like you were
saying are we going to look back this
and say is this the Battle of eal pass
to me it reminds me more of the standoff
at Ruby Ridge right there was a time
when we saw the federal government being
aggressive and we waited to see what
would happen in this case Ruby Ridge was
a handful of people but I'm I'm what I'm
saying is it's interesting to look back
and say you know at the time the federal
government said we're justified in what
we're doing and we look back and say
like was that the correct thing to do
will we look back at the border people
who don't necessarily see illegal
immigration as a problem and will they
look back at it and sayet it yeah will
they say oh we should have let the razor
wire stay oh we oh we know why Texas is
we understand this now because we live
with the consequences of those actions
well and this is why this is not a time
for weak politicians I mean it really
isn't this is a time where we're need
some some patriots to get involved in
politics we have too many politicians in
politics because a politician's not
going to send in the National Guard from
West Virginia Ohio or Kentucky but a
patriot someone like Carrie Lake because
she was in charge of Arizona right now
guarante their National Guard would be
doing the same thing right now at the
Arizona border one of her campaign ex I
I think West Virginia state governance
should immediately have an investigation
into the CBP facility yes they should be
subpoenaing records they should be
getting warrants they should be going
through all their documents to what
degree is is the CBP in West Virginia
working with or facilitating the
trafficking that's happening at the
border because we know and I'm wondering
how much this affects West Virginia we
know that CBP is bringing these people
to airports to uh to uh Bus Charters and
having them sent around the country in
an interview one of these guys says
they're given a was like A2 or $3,000
gift card and they're given
accommodation and places to sleep I I I
do not believe West Virginia is not one
of these destinations I think it is
extremely likely these people are being
sent here to the extent that they can be
right due to infrastructure I think the
fact that we know and I've seen on video
and you can go down there and witness it
for yourself that CBP agents are engaged
in human trafficking that's more than
enough probable cause for the legal
apparatus of West Virginia to go in with
a bunch of guys in in police jackets and
start ripping through those documents to
figure out what it is CBP is doing and
why they're doing it I think anybody who
works for CBP at this point who hasn't
resigned over this is a scumbag well let
me just say if our West Virginia elected
legislators and elected officials are
not going to do that then they should
everyone be primaried and kicked out of
office because if they don't have the
courage to step up and do that when it's
happening in our state because they they
love everybody loves to sit back and say
oh this is happening over another this
is happening I didn't know this is
happening in West Virginia this is crazy
to me because I'm on the other we don't
know what is happening well I know but I
mean that there was a facility there I
should say I didn't know this and so I
agree I I think at the very least there
should be some proper investigations
into that I mean we know there's 85,000
missing children that we know of right
now well and there's there's got to be
more than that right because there's a
rule and this was again this was like a
judge who said that uh um it was like a
you know the Flores settlement this
whole thing so basically like a judge
said that children need to be released
unaccompanied minors need to be released
they can't be held without you know for
like very long time or whatever and they
were very displeased with the the
conditions that children were being held
in so it was like okay the children have
to be released children would be
released there'd be sponsors Etc DHS
doesn't even know who the sponsors are
there's no vetting and then after and
this was like in when was the Flores
thing it was like in the 90s or
something like that but it keeps coming
up and then Obama took the Flores
settlement and was like okay well um
we're going to have to separate the kids
from the adults and that's how family
separation started you separate the kids
from the adults so that the kids would
be released but you wouldn't be
releasing the adults and then this you
know it comes up again and it turns out
now you have to release the adults with
the children if they come across and it
creates this golden ticket situation and
you don't even know who the adults are
and you have like so many reporters have
gone down and reported on the border
showing that people uh before they cross
the border they'll ditch their ID
documents yeah they show them laying
there around the Border people need to
remember your tax dollars are paying for
our own government to you're aiding and
edding the child's sex trafficking of
children it's crazy when you look at the
effect and the impact you can only start
to believe that this is what they wanted
to happens absolutely they they must
want a huge cartel backed child sex ring
happening in the United States they must
want lots of our citizens to be dying
from fenel overdoses they must want that
they must want show that they they were
literally like think about it at one
point they were saying all the the
border the borderers closed they were
just you know saying it was blond but
then Texas it starts building their own
you know their own barriers and the Joe
Biden Administration the Democrats are
actively suing to open it back up every
time so they can't even hide from this
anymore and pretend that it's not that
polic oh well Congress has to do
something but we're going to sue so we
have the right to do it and I would veto
any build they're literally fighting to
open the border and and and allow our
country to be invaded like they're on
there there there's no way around it
they're the bad guys here are the CBP
agents themselves yeah they're the Nazi
guards
and I will say this right now I I will
lighten up a little bit to the CBP
agents that may hear this you know I
assume if you're just now finding out
like you work let's say you work in the
facility over off 340 and you're filing
paperwork and you do accounting stuff
and you have no idea what's going on
okay I think it's fair that upon
discovery of what the B Administration
is doing you resigning is the noble
thing to do for those that know exactly
what's going on and what's being done
and either are complicit involved in it
or knowing it's happening don't care and
say leave me out of it I'll take my
paycheck I I I will say there is nothing
I pray for more right now than to see
these people rot in prison for the rest
of their
lives you can come to me and you can
offer me an infinity pool of Ferrari a
great Mansion I'll say I want none of
those things you come to me and say
we'll give you one thing I say I want
those people arrested I want them in
jail I want each and every one of these
CBP agents that's down there on the
board arrested by the Texas National
Guard and Texas state troopers and
locked up and I want them to cry and say
but why and it's because you're a human
Smuggler you
scumbags these people are are are abject
evil they are quite literally the I
should say figuratively the demons in
the devil's Army I mean that
figuratively perhaps some people believe
it literally this this smuggling
operation that we are seeing that has
Eric Adams in panic Democrats freaking
out people in Chicago in uproar their
schools are being taken over and is
these agents on the border with smiles
on their faces saying I don't know I'm
getting paid just doing my job just
doing my I'm getting paid it's great I
get my paycheck hey man I don't care
about what's happening to this country I
don't care what happens to you I don't
care how many people die I don't I don't
care how many people die trying to cross
through these deserts they are getting
paid and that's all they care about I
hope if anything and I I don't believe
this will happen but I really hope that
when Donald Trump gets elected one of
the first things he does is sends
federal agents to arrest all of the
agents that were involved in the human
smuggling operations it's the first
thing he does when he begins his Mass
wave of deportations he says the first
thing we have to do is stop the human
smuggling operation and those who who
facilitated it we know for a fact who it
was because their names are all in our
books and so I'm going to make sure I do
everything in my power that I Lobby
every politician I know that I speak
with anyone I know who's working in
government and say I expect these men to
be in prison now to be fair I expect
criminal charges to be brought against
them the evidence to be be presented in
court of law and for the sentence to be
uh
um warranted for the crime committed and
I don't know how many years do you think
you get for human smuggling I'm going to
look it up not enough yeah probably not
maybe just a couple hundred hours
community service oh yeah something like
that the weed psychosis lady no but look
you know there's going to be some guy
who's 23 and he's like I don't know my
boss just told me to be a human Smuggler
and I'm like okay I'm looking forward to
the day you cry and you cry as you're
being ripped from your home and and
thrown into the back do you think that
some of these people should be charged
with treason for aiding and abetting the
in not treason it's sedition or sedition
do you think some of these people should
be charged with with some of that I know
there's a little bit different than the
traffing correct so the higher ranking
agents who are aware of what's going on
yes they're involved in a s seditious
conspiracy I think the agents On the
Border who are just told hey be a human
Smuggler like they know they're
trafficking humans there's no way they
don't know this they know so that would
be a human ignorance smuggling uh
non-citizens into the US looks like it's
punishable by up to 20 years in prison
great that's a good amount of time it
could be extended to life if someone
dies as a result well there's been a lot
that's died and there are already
stories that we've pulled up where
people have been criminally charged by
the doj for transporting within the
country criminal aliens so there were
two soldiers two uh uh enlisted guys who
didn't smuggle These Guys across the
border they were just transporting them
knowing they were getting paid to do it
and they went to prison that was several
years ago I think that was during the
Trump trump years now the Biden
Administration ordered these guys to be
criminal I'm sorry dude if your boss
comes to you and says rob a bank and you
go I guess I have to do it I look
forward to seeing you in prison I just
now real quick the higher-ups in the
Biden Administration seditious
conspiracy 100% lock them up I just
think this is the point where people who
work as border agents for the federal
government should consider leaving for
you know to be a border uh agent joining
the Texas National Guard they should
move to the state level because seems at
least in this case like the states are
willing to do something the federal
government government isn't which is to
defend the rights of the people in their
communities uh I get that the idea of
being like you can't just ask them to
leave their jobs is scary I understand
that but they are in a specialized
career where as far as I know it's
chronically underst staffed at the state
and federal level so they could leave
they could change they at least be
whistleblowers no no no no no no no no
no no no you come to me and you say Tim
I can't quit my job because my kids need
food and I say okay what's your job I
work at the the cracker Factory and I I
want to support Trump my company's super
woke and I'm scared if I speak up I'll
get fired how am I going to feed my
family I say well that's that's a tough
position I understand I do uh do your
best make money protect your family you
come to me and say I can't quit my job
my kid needs food I go what's your job
I'm a human Smuggler I say I look
forward to seeing you locked up I look
forward to the day yeah your children
are crying as they are ripped from your
arms as you were thrown in the back of a
police van for being a human Smuggler
you you do not get to live in the
comfort of your own home as a human
Smuggler you are you are these these are
some of the darkest and most evil
actions a person could engage in and
these guys are like well my boss told me
to do it I don't care but you zero
sympathy lock them up you could also
have a boss on a state level that's like
no no more razor wire don't do that like
you're choosing to work for the federal
government where this is the order
you're getting there are states that
that wouldn't make you do this sure quit
you're if you're in CBP quit right now
if you work for the customs and board of
protection and you are getting a pay
check knowing what they are doing and
you say yeah but my kid needs food I
want you in prison I don't care I have
no sympathy whatsoever I don't care what
job you're doing you are facilitating
this when we have the majority of people
in this country citing immigration as
the principal issue when you have
Democrats and Republicans in up when
Biden laughs and says the border is not
secure knowing what he's doing and
you're like I'm part of an organization
that operates human smuggling operation
and I'm like stop don't do that and you
go but my kids need food okay well bank
robbers kids need food and when they say
I robbed a b cuz I wanted to feed my
family we still put them in prison I
think that's I I think a that's a
reasonable point it it does remind me a
lot of the you know the the Nazi guards
who were just doing their jobs we still
dragged a bunch of them back from
Argentina or wherever and put them on
trial at the ha didn't we do that some
point you got to look yourself in the
mirror and ask if what you're doing is
moral or not I mean that's what it this
is everything we're really dealing with
in our country is in my opinion is
spiritual warfare we got a lot of good
versus evil going on in our country and
people to Tim's point you know they make
excuses and say well I'm just doing this
or I've got to do it for this reason and
but what you're doing is one of the most
cruel unjust things you could ever do
which is aiding and ab betting and
actually participating in smuggling not
just humans but I mean children this is
absolutely despicable and and I love
your outrage and I share it with
you I I'm you know we had uh Michael ma
came on the show a long time ago and he
said that I'm paraphrasing but the
actions of politicians are letters to
Santa without the police yeah it is the
actions of and and so I've had a lot of
people try to make this play politicians
come in here like oh no no you can't
blame the cops they're good people it's
the leadership that's bad I say I don't
care about leadership Bill DeBlasio can
go out in the middle of the street Buck
Naked screaming into the wind for all I
care it's meaningless but if he does it
and the cops then protect him while he's
doing it now that's the problem the
individual officers who are engaging in
this activity this goes back to when
DeBlasio stole taxpayer funds to paint
black lives matter in front of Trump's
uh fth Avenue building and then used I
think it was like 27 police officers to
protect it so stealing from the public
coffers for a political purpose for
personal gain and those cops had Smiles
on their faces while they they did what
they were told that's that's that's
that's policing in New York City now I
mean what we're seeing at Eagle Pass and
not just Eagle Pass but in Arizona and
New Mexico is shocking what is an
80-year old guy how's that old man uh I
think he's 82 but I'll double check
cartel active on his property he defends
himself they arrest him they lock him up
that's why that's why I'm I'm I'm like
no there's there's no sympathy at this
point it's not just about one thing
happening one time it's about the state
of the country and where we are right
now where you defend your property you
go to prison 74 sorry he was 74 years
old just like the M him so dramatically
remember the mclusky they to get a
pardon just just for standing outside of
their home being like don't you guys
come in people broke in ripped the fence
down and brandished firearms and they
got in trouble for it and that's the
thing though like if I I really believe
if the American people thought that they
were able to go to the border and help
Texas National Guard defend the border
right now and secure a border you would
see American Patriots who would
willingly go do this but they can't
because they're going to get thrown in
prison if they were to even think about
doing that they even if they went down
there at all I mean they're threatened
to arrest people for holding a video
camera and videotaping could you imagine
happen yeah could you imagine if someone
was down there saying we're not going to
let you in what they would do to these
people well isn't it crazy that Texas
had a make had to make a law that
illegally entering Texas from an
international border was illegal yeah
that's just insane they started
arresting people the other day the
Federal Government tried stopping them
yeah well and and there's there's really
Technically when you get into the the
roles of the federal government they're
really Limited in what they're supposed
to do they've gotten way too big for
their britches and and everything but
one of the few things are yeah but one
of the things they're supposed to do is
actually secure the Border you have so
many few true jobs and won't do it and
they're supposed to protect States from
Invasion what is it like yeah they're
supposed to definitely do that it's
interesting looking at the Supreme Court
um and giving them the benefit of the
doubt right like let's say we could give
them the benefit of the doubt uh if you
look at some of their other cases
recently or if you look at the oral
arguments in Chevron the other day uh
the EPA versus West Virginia even dos if
you look at these things what they're
doing is they are handing power back to
the legislators they're taking it away
from the courts they're saying you know
and if you look at this situation
they're saying the court this Lower
Court does not have the right to decide
what the federal government can do in
this border situation so you wonder like
perhaps the Texas state legislature
should start taking this stuff up you
know and perhaps Congress should look
into impeaching some of these Supreme
Court Justices were doing I know I would
I'm tell right now day
oneing May orcus it doesn't make any
sense that they're not thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8:00 p.m. and become a
member over at timcast.net